la otan es un producto de la guerra fría
y el instrumento de eeuu para perpetuar
su hegemonía e influir en la política de
defensa europea lo ha dicho
recientemente el portavoz del ministerio
exteriores chino y es sólo una de las
muchas críticas que se amontonan en las
vísperas de la cumbre de la organización
en madrid y se espera que a petición de
eeuu se identifique por primera vez a
china en la estrategia de la
organización y eso ocurrirá se recuerda
aquí sin que china haya participado en
ninguna guerra en casi medio siglo sin
que haya abandonado su neutralidad en el
conflicto ucraniano y sin que comparta
fronteras con ninguno de los países
miembros de la otan a china le inquieta
la presión militar creciente de eeuu en
su patio trasero con organizaciones de
defensa como el aucas y el quad que son
descritas a menudo como la otan de asia
ahora además corre el riesgo de que se
añada la verdadera otan a china le
preocupa que países como corea del sur
japón australia y nueva zelanda
participen por primera vez en una cumbre
de la otan sobre ellas aclara la prensa
nacional de que corren el riesgo de
convertirse en peones de la política
belicista de eeuu